if you're a fan of gary vaynerchuck and
you're looking for ways to not worry
about being judged changed your
environment and not overthink things
then this video is for you people try to
build the biggest building in town by
tearing everybody else's building down
when you have enough talent to just
build the biggest building you just
build the biggest building I can give up
about anybody else I'm doing me
you know like those cliche things like
if you want to get to the top of
mountain it's like one step at a time I
believe in that who you surround
yourself matters what content you
consume matters what's that bleep nation
it's having my one we're just believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift this I do that I want to
see exploded onto the world I started
the mentor me seriously try to hang
around people who've done a lot more
than us and hopefully by spending a
little more time with them some of their
mindset their belief system their way of
thinking seeps into us to help us become
the best version of ourselves so today
we're going to learn from one of the
best Gary Vaynerchuk and some of his
best motivation for 2018 mentor me Gary
[Music]
you
I only want one thing for people that I
have really outside of health the only
thing I wish for people is them to love
what they do as much as I do when I do
new podcasts or new video shows I love
reading the comments of the audience
that don't know me
inevitably 5% of the audience will leave
a comment that refers to drugs if they
want to be really snarky they'll say I
you know cocaine ritalin you know they
they think that I'm on something and I
always reply because I've never tried
smoking a cigarette let alone done
adderall I reply with grat the answer so
they'll say cocaine and I'll reply
gratitude I'm so grateful that I do what
I love everyday and what I love for
clarification is just being an
entrepreneur playing the challenges the
risk the excitement but you also have
tremendous energy because it builds
momentum when you're doing what you want
to be doing for a long period of time it
builds momentum I didn't have the same
energy in school I hated school I was
optimistic I was high energy that's my
DNA but not like this this is now a
supernova
because now I'm 20 years into being in
my zone the the breath of fresh air the
exhale I had on the first day that I
worked at my dad's liquor store like
worked like there was no more school
ever again that was incredible I think
the fundamental separation that I have
is really predicated on two things I
have empathy so I'm thinking about what
you're thinking about and number two I
don't
in the short term if you really actually
understand what I just said on those two
things if you're actually consumer
centric and you don't need money in the
short term you always look like a juice
it's I don't like people and I don't
like companies and businesses that are
ideological like there's way too many
enthusiasts here that would like to see
this happen
I don't like to anything to happen I
just want to try to figure out what I
think is going to happen and a lot of
times that's put me on it in a place
where people judged me and made fun of
me until they didn't all my friends made
fun of me that I signed a case with
sneaker deal because I had the audacity
to think it would work until it all sold
out in four hours
and then they stopped laughing
and the reason it worked was because I
understood where attention sat right I
mean and that's how I think about the
world when something works you're a
genius when it doesn't work here fool
success has unlimited fathers now
everybody thinks they were involved late
babban thinks he's the reason the case
was sneaker sold right but failure has
none right yeah I mean look but that's
what makes it fun if you're in a place
where you're comfortable with accepting
your losses I'm proud to say up here
that I've had a pivot Baner smart
because the timing of IOT hasn't worked
in the way that I thought it would
that's comfortable to me she wants in
the market yeah
to me that's comfortably I'm so sad that
so many of you don't do things because
you're worried about being judged it
makes me sad like that sucks you know
like to me that's my loss like what's
that got to do with you like I don't
give a [ __ ] what you think Marco you
know like like you know like I'm doing
my thing and so when you start getting
comfortable with losing in the micro
well then you can really start doing
things I don't want to be a charlatan or
a motivational speaker or you know those
aren't interesting to me but I'm also
willing to people to judge me and
misunderstand me because I know how this
all plays out at the end so you can move
me in the second
I'll talk to you after the game I work
by you like while everybody's debating
I'm doing it and I'm willing to take
micro losses for macro wins and most
people aren't because they want
short-term money or they actually value
other people's opinions over their own I
realize that I mean nothing which then
doesn't allow me to have the audacity to
be cynical or scored skeptical
it's really you know when I I'm
empathetic and my late parents having
sex at the right moment giving me DNA
like this is not me but I'm like why am
I not skeptical why am I not cynical oh
because it's my opinion mean in that
bird like I had like the amount of
people dropping their two cents on
social media just on somebody like they
mean something
people try to build the biggest building
in town by tearing everybody else's
building down when you have enough
talent to just build the biggest
building you just build the biggest
building I can give a [ __ ] about anybody
else I'm doing me and honestly I wish
all of you the best and I even really
hope you beat me because that will keep
me hungry but the truth is I'm not
worried about other people [ __ ]
like we're just we're counting everybody
else's points too much worry about your
own now that bubble will burst and then
we'll get to see who's still around and
then we'll see everybody else who says
entrepreneur in their Instagram profile
right now when they're working in Bank
of America in 24 months and so that's
what I'm waiting for I'm I'm I'm most
excited for and waiting for and hoping
for complete global economic Parnas so
that we can weed out the B and C and D
players I think the world like lacks
optimism I think you know everyone's
like your energy your energy I've come
to realize it's just an optimism
I'm just happy just positive that's what
it is
just like whatever chemicals are my body
they just allow me to see the bright
side like and I just don't think I've
realized how few people have that like
know very few people have it as black
and white hundred zero like I just think
everything's good but like you know I'm
dying no out of eight billion people
like what the breakdown is like my gut
is like six billion just go directly
into having more pessimism and cynicism
and negativity like 5149 minimally all
the way down to very scary places and I
just don't think there's a lot of 80 80
% optimism
just environment raised like it's just
all that stuff I forced myself to be
optimistic every day does not come
naturally I get it Susan it doesn't come
naturally a lot of people I think I
think that's like you know if I was able
to say I'm lucky about something forget
about the business results it's lucky
that that optimism comes naturally to me
like I'm just optimistic like I just
think that so much works for me because
I refuse to accept the negative like I
you know and I don't think I hate when
people say it's you know it's an option
or it's a choice I agree with you Susan
I don't think it comes natural to
everybody I think we are just starting
on the early stages of a really looking
at mental health the brain meditation
and I do think alike
that's like saying be beautiful doesn't
come natural to everybody some of us you
know yes I'm just kidding
but like you know like you know I I do
think that some of some things are are
matched with us early on and I'm I'm so
grateful I sit here in front of the
2,000 of you which is in itself is
ridiculous like I can turn something on
in three minutes and have 2,000 people
here enough to hear what I have to say I
see with here with ego and humility
gratitude and focus appreciation and
sense of responsibility all built around
really this optimistic foundation that
is the fuel that drives me to my hustle
and to my execution in the marketplace I
realized what's going on here one life I
realized that I'm living like this is
our only at-bat and most of you are in
people walking around here like they're
coming back walking around here like
they're coming back you're not coming
back well listen I don't want to impose
my beliefs on others maybe you believe
to come back I believe you'll come back
to come back as a tree or a flower pot
or d-roc sneakers and that blows
compared to being a human and so I'm
acting that way I'm acting that way I
think the next step is to not overly
think about the next step you know like
those cliche things like if you want to
get to the top of mountain it's like one
step at a time I believe in that like I
think the biggest things that cripples a
guy like you too
years in starting to build something you
know you get a little taste and you want
more right that's always a dangerous
part I'm very scared
usually at year two three four of a
little bit of momentum that's where a
lot of people try to go too fast and
break the whole thing get a little fancy
get either content or too hungry it's
about staying in the middle and
remembering what got you there I mean
look I'm a great example of it you know
I always want people to watch me
carefully
like I'm winning I've gotten fancy and
I'm getting less fancy like I'm trying
like you know as good things are
happening for me I'm trying to go more
tried and Treo as the light gleams I'm
trying to go more into being an operator
I'm gonna speak less next year I'm gonna
operate more I'm gonna do more HR and
see my people like I think it's just
important to I don't think about what's
next ever like of course I'm thinking
every day about what I want to do that's
going to help me win but I don't think
of it as next I think people look at it
like you know and I just look at it like
and so I think the best way to have
something happened that's going to bring
you value is remembering what got you
there what got you to where you are
right now is you got motivated you took
a camera out from your phone and you
started doing and then good started
happening and I think a lot of people
start overthinking and putting too much
pressure on themselves for what's next
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think it
more as strategy what's your strategy in
life somebody asked me on Instagram
after I posted a scary if the mindset
has been skewed how can you bring it
back and I answered with by surrounding
yourself with people who have the
mindset you aspire to my friends please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple
now it's
very hard to cut people with pessimism
cynicism and negativity when they are
the people that are the closest to you
parents siblings spouse but the bottom
line is if you're asking the question
I'm gonna give you the answer the answer
is add more people with positivity and
optimism and cut people with pessimism
and cynicism who you surround yourself
matters what content you consume matters
I basically suffocate myself for a long
period of my time and created an
environment that was based on offense
and optimism and now I know no different
please do the same for you make that
move mold and I mean mold your mindset
by what you consume and with whom you
consume it I would argue that well more
than 50% of the people in this audience
are here today because they worry about
the way they would be judged by one
and/or two family members in their you
know seven eight people circle if you're
not feeling it find new friends I'm
being dead serious about this this one
is real big for me who you hang out with
is a huge Yannick and these are all
trying true things right we've heard the
you're the whatever of the five friends
you spent like that's real add one new
winner friend like you know what I mean
I had one new winner friend and cut one
loser friend like yeah I know he's been
your boy since fourth grade but he sits
at home and smokes weed and plays 2k all
day like you can only love him so much
now I've got a special Gary Vaynerchuk
bonus clip for you but before getting to
that the question of the day is I'm
curious what is your favorite thing
about Gary Vaynerchuk what's your
favorite personality trait over the
lesson that you learn the most from him
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon and
enjoy the bonus
thing that has always worked for me is
never allowing somebody to have leverage
on you this [ __ ] because I didn't want
to that person that's me that would like
good that would like me to like that's
great but I don't even like the key is
to like I've gotten to the point where I
don't even realize I'm missing it
anymore because you can cut it becomes
practice honestly I'll give you a good
example look at our table right now do
you know how serious amount of food this
is for so many people around the world
right so I look at this right this is
how I look at your question there's so
much to me you don't need so I don't
think like oh I better go like like for
you right it's like oh I hate that
person but that person is the person
that plays the record or that person
picks the playlist for the 84 million
person playlist on Spotify or SoundCloud
I'm I'm kind of just like I'm at like
like I don't even like like I'm like to
me this is why if you really break down
what I'm always saying I'm just like
brings so much value to the end person
so that you have the most leverage
Amazon gives us the best thing we love
Amazon because it's the best buying
experience thus Amazon will kill
everybody else because they're the best
of the consumer I want your control of
the thing that most people see because
if you bring the most value then you
have the leverage everybody comes to me
because I'm giving value at scale with
no expectation of anything else
[Music]
wolves long media the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be to
like a little beacon pay believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]